bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés ce soir
avec nos invités en plateau nous avons
évoqué un sujet qui fait débat
maintenant depuis plus de 15 ans les 35
heures et pour en parler ce soir flavie
hors toulouse est avocate au barreau de
versailles vous intervenez
principalement dans le domaine du droit
du travail et les relations sociales
également avec nous florence mercadé
choqué vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration et du bureau du medef
78 jean-luc madec
vous êtes-vous restaurateurs le patron
du restaurant les templiers qui se
trouve elle en cours et enfin sonia
porot vous êtes la secrétaire
départementale du syndicat cgt
alors faut-il ou ne faut-il pas revenir
sur le temps légal du travail faut-il
abroger la loi aubry qui fixe les 35
heures comme cadre légal en france un
sujet qui revient sur le devant de
l'actualité avec le rapport badinter un
rapport remis récemment à manuel valls
le premier ministre pour une réforme du
code du travail est une chose est déjà
sûre une chose est déjà acté les 35
heures ne seront pas en tant que telle
remise en cause
on commence avec vous le medef 78
florence marcadet choqué ce que c'est
une déception que les 35 heures en tant
que telle ne seront pas remises en cause
non ce n'est pas une déception parce
qu'on s'attendait pas du tout à ce qu'il
y ait une remise en cause des 35 heures
et à la limite ce n'est pas
nécessairement une revendication du
medef de dire il faut à tout prix
remettre en cause une notion de durée
légale
notre position c'est plutôt de dire
laissons aux aux branches et aux
entreprises le soin de pouvoir évaluer
quelle est la durée du travail dans tel
type d'activité ou dans tel type
d'entreprise et il faut effectivement de
toute façon une durée pour déclencher
des heures supplémentaires donc on n'est
pas contre le fait de fixer une durée du
travail avec un déclenchement des heures
supplémentaires c'est pas le sujet mais
qu'on puisse laisser aux entreprises et
aux branches le soin de pouvoir en
fonction de ces activités-là de savoir
quelle est la bonne durée du travail à
partir de quel moment déclencher un
supporter pendant longtemps une
revendication de temps
début des années 2000 aujourd'hui ça ne
l'est ça ne l'est plus non mais je crois
que c'est tellement ancré les 35 heures
sont maintenant complètement ancré dans
les moeurs et dans les sociétés il ya
des accords d'entreprise qui sont faits
sur la base de 35 heures je pense que
venir faire exploser tous les accords
qui existent sur des annualisation sur
des forfaits jours sur des tas de choses
base est quand même sur la réforme de la
durée du travail
aubry sur les 35 heures ce serait assez
peu réaliste et je pense pas notamment
sur des entreprises importantes que ce
soit une de leur volonté
sonia porot pour vous le fait qu'on ne
touche pas aux 35 heures c'est ce qu'a
annoncé notamment la ministre du travail
mais quand même elle comrie c'est
quelque chose qui est de nature à vous
rassurer ou pas pas spécialement parce
que la position de la cgt l'analyse
c'est qu'on a besoin de regarder non
seulement la durée légale du travail qui
effectivement déclenché les heures
supplémentaires mais surtout la durée
réelle du travail pour les salariés
et comment ce temps de travail est
organisée pour les dire qu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas vraiment à 35 heures
officiellement on est plus à 37 39
heures c'est ce que disent la plupart
des rapports oui aujourd'hui la durée
moyenne des salariés à temps plein c'est
quasiment 39 heures par contre on a
aussi un salarié sur cinq qui est à
temps partiel et là c'est plutôt en
moyenne
23 24 heures donc c'est aussi des
disparités
et puis après il ya toutes les formes
d'organisation du travail c'est à dire
les horaires de travail du samedi du
dimanche le travail de nuit est ce qu'on
est en trois huit ans de huit toutes ses
formes d'organisation du travail
elles ont des impacts sur la santé des
salariés sur leur vie personnelle
donc c'est ça qu'on a besoin de regarder
et aujourd'hui par contre à la cgt on
pense que oui il faudrait regarder à
nouveau diminuer la durée du travail
mais dans l'idée de travailler tous de
travailler moins et de travailler mieux
en dessous des 35 heures il ya un seuil
que la cgt pense bon pour les salariés
justement pour les ouvriers
aujourd'hui on réfléchi autour des 32
heures pour l'ensemble des salariés
parce que on est dans un département où
il ya une forte population d'ingénieurs
de cadres et de techniciens et eux leur
durée du travail
elle est plutôt autour de 44 heures par
semaine voire quasiment quarante sept
heures pour les cadres au forfait jours
par contre leur salaire il est basé sur
35 heures donc il ya vraiment besoin de
réfléchir à ce sujet là et les données
que que je cite sont celles de la dares
jean-luc madec en tant que chef
d'entreprise d'un restaurant où les
heures de travail peuvent être
compliqués à gérer on le sait quel est
votre point de vue à vous sur les 35
heures est ce que pour votre affaire
c'est un frein concret ce seuil légal du
temps de travail ou alors c'est bon pour
la santé de vos salariés qui peuvent
travailler parfois tard où beaucoup
alors les 35 heures n'ont rien à voir
avec la santé de nos salariés
les 35 heures c'est une loi je pense
qu'elle est rentrée dans les moeurs on y
reviendra pas
par contre il faut encourager le travail
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on gagne sa
vie et que on acquiert la promotion
sociale dont on a tous besoin on vit par
conséquent je pense que dans nos métiers
en particulier il faut que les 35 heures
restent la loi de base d'ailleurs chez
nous c'est 39 puisqu'il ya comment sont
collectives
dans notre métier autorise sa
sensibilité particulière pendant cinq
heures hanter leurs taux normal est 4
heures payées en heures supplémentaires
à 10% supplémentaires bien
et au delà on est à 25 % d'ailleurs donc
nous ce que l'on dit simplement c'est la
loi telle qu'elle est ne va bien la
grande problématique à laquelle nous
avons eu à faire à partir de 2012
ça a été la refiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires qui du coup a mis un
coup d'arrêt au volontariat dans les
heures sup pour nos salariés et qui a
créé de vraies difficultés dans nos
entreprises
bon maintenant qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour nous petites entreprises
en règle générale et petite surprise de
service en particulier mine de rien les
petites entreprises de moins de 20
salariés en france c'est 2 millions et
demi d'entreprise ces 66 % des salariés
en france est considérable donc on donne
nous deux demandes particulières la
première ne revenait pas sur la loi sur
le temps de travail
elle est comme elle est par contre donné
de l'assouplissement pour permettre à
des salariés de travailler comme il le
souhaite
avec bien entendu les compensations
salariales qui vont avec il n'est pas
question de payer les heures sup au même
prix que des heures normales combien
d'heures de travail par exemple dans
votre restaurant fait un salarié culte
et nous les salariés font 39 heures par
contre si un jour on a un surplus
d'activité et qu'un salarié de venir sur
un jour de congé et bien on lui demande
s'il souhaite le faire et en
l'occurrence là il est beaucoup mieux
rémunérés bien évidemment la grande
problématique aujourd'hui c'est la
teneur des contraintes administratives
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés pour
vous donner un ordre d'idée un salarié
en heures sup ses sept pages de
documents bon est-ce que ça suce
justifie peut-être pas pour des toutes
petites entreprises comme les nôtres
mais par le sud martiaux de salariés lui
se dit bon bassiste rails en heures sup
je vais fiscalisés sûr mais ensuite je
risque de sauter une tranche d'impôts
est ce que j et intérêts il dit que pas
beaucoup finalement en tout cas le les
arbitrages que va mener le gouvernement
vont se porter plutôt aujourd'hui sur la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
on a commencé à évoquer le sujet flavie
porteuses ou un petit point sur le cadre
légal aujourd'hui on peut travailler
plus de 35 heures en hausse et les
heures supplémentaires sont majorés de
combien de % et jusqu'à quel seuil est
finalement cadre légal et déjà quand
même assez souple
niveau de la loi c'est à ces soupes sert
qu il peut y avoir si l'accord de
branche le prévoit une majoration qui
est déjà à 10 % j'entends souvent parler
des 10% faut que l'accord de branche le
prévoit et il peut y avoir cette
majoration la face et la corse et non
ses 25% 16 ans effectivement à défaut
d'accord et donc c'est déjà le cas c'est
25% et 50% à compter de la huitième
heure situe pas de bêtises c'est bien ça
aujourd'hui en france on peut travailler
par exemple sur le souhaitent 70 heures
par semaine
non c'est un petit peu à chaque fois le
même le même sujet c'est pas tellement
les 35 heures qui font la limitation et
la durée réelle du travail 35 heures
c'est juste un seuil au delà je suis en
heures supplémentaires en dessous je
suis à temps partiel c'est rien d'autre
que ça c'est une référence
après au niveau des deux ce qui limite
vraiment et ce qui protège vraiment les
salariés c'est plutôt les durées
maximales de travail
on est à combien en france aujourd'hui
sur une semaine alors il ya des
principes et plein de dérogation en
principe comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs
dix heures par jour
quarante huit heures par semaine donc ça
c'est les durées maximales de travail
apprendra les durée minimale de repos
donc là vous avez le maximum travaillez
vous avez le minimum de repos là vous
êtes à 11h par 11 heures quotidiennes
plus 25 heures par semaine ça fait 35
heures par semaine
en tout cas le seuil minimum pour
majorer aujourd'hui les heures
supplémentaires c'est 10 % est ce que ce
que c'est un seuil sur lequel il
faudrait revenir par exemple florence
marcadet choqué ce qu'il faut pas que
évoqué un moment plus ou moins emmanuel
macron oui mais après un moment donné
est parti
quand il était à davos en faisant une
déclaration en disant après tout une
heure supplémentaire devrait pas être
payés plus qu'une heure normale
la position du medef là dessus est très
claire on n'a pas l'intention de faire
des compensations tout à fait symbolique
je pense que voilà on a un cadre légal
qui est il ya des heures sup ya des
heures sup maintenant le débat une fois
de plus ce n'est pas forcément il est
sur une compensation 10%
voilà c'est déjà la règle dans un
certain nombre de conventions
collectives d'accord de branche pas
descendre en dessous mais une fois de
plus tout notre position c'est laissons
un peu plus de flexibilité dans les
entreprises et dans les branches pour
dire à partir de quel moment on
déclenche parce qu'il ya des durées de
travail dans des entreprises
l'entreprise de jean luc c'est 39 heures
il est vrai que la moyenne
travailler en français 39 heures on
aimerait vraiment rester en fait sur 39
heures comme avant finalement quand on
dit que les français travaillent pas
assez fou donc les français travaillent
plus que certain nombre d'autres peuples
européens
mais le débat s'est laissons un peu plus
de flexibilité dans les entreprises
justement peut-être pour dire à partir
de quel moment que les havrais durée du
travail que l'on rémunère normalement et
à partir de quand on va pouvoir
déclencher les heures supplémentaires et
juste pour ajouter une autre chose sur
l'encadrement des heures supplémentaires
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on travaillait en
39 heures avec quatre heures
supplémentaires par semaine ça
correspond au contingent d'heures
supplémentaires annuelles que l'on a par
an et par salarié c'est à dire qu'on a
le droit de faire travailler chaque
salarié alors ça c'est dans le code du
travail après il ya d'autres montants
dans les conventions collectives
deux cent vingt heures par an et par
salarié or ces 220 heures correspondent
en fait à 169 heures par mois ce qui
veut dire que déjà en plafonnant
contingent d'heures supplémentaires et
si on va au delà du contingent de
contingents d'heures supplémentaires il
ya des majorations beaucoup plus
importante il faut peut-être réfléchir
globalement à l'activité de chaque
société de chaque entreprise et de voir
comment on peut moduler ce temps de
travail sonia porot sur le seuil des 10%
qui a un temps été évoqué par emmanuel
macron rien n'est décidé pour le moment
même on semble plutôt sur le fait de
rester ainsi dans la future loi sur le
code du travail
quel est votre point de vue je pense
qu'il faut quand même garder une
majoration assez conséquente des heures
supplémentaires sinon effectivement la
durée du
du travail n'a plus n'a plus beaucoup de
sens après encore une fois si on part de
la réalité
on a d'abord un problème à rémunérer
réellement toutes les heures travaillées
il ya un certain nombre d'heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas comptabilisés dans toutes
sortes d'entreprises grandes ou petites
on a encore une fois des salariés qui
sont en dehors de ce cadre là des 35
heures je pense aux assistantes
maternelles par exemple qui sont
nombreuses dans le département elles
elles sont largement au dessus de 40
heures de travail 45 heures par par
semaine et les 35 heures ont permis de
diminuer malgré tout la durée du travail
c'est à dire qu'on était bien au-dessus
de 40 heures en moyenne auparavant
et ça a suscité effectivement des
aspirations chez les salariés celle
d'avoir du temps libre
celle de pouvoir effectivement profité
de ce temps mais derrière il ya déjà eu
beaucoup de souplesse
beaucoup d'entreprises ont un temps de
travail qui est annualisé
ça veut dire des semaines des fois où on
fait 40 heures des semaines où on va en
faire 20 ou 30
il ya tout le problème aussi de la durée
j'avais dire sur sur l'année et même sur
sur la ville le temps de travail c'est
vraiment un élément fondamental dans la
vie du salarié et c'est comment on
encadre la durée effective du travail
moi je connais pas d'entreprises où il
n'ya pas effectivement des débats sur la
prise en compte du temps de pause sur le
temps d'habillage de déshabillage ou le
temps de lancement des applications
donc l'enjeu il est déjà la prise en
compte réelle du temps de travail
effectif
jean le cam avec vous souhaitiez
peut-être réagir ce qu'il a dit écoutez
nous comme je vous le dis on est sur les
35 heures on a une particule est on
utilise surtout sur la restauration
c'est que l'on à des coupures vous savez
chez nous personne ne travaille le midi
et au service du soir
il est clair que la base sur leur
politique de la mise en place des 35
heures avait pour objet de pouvoir faire
travailler - plus de monde pour
incontestablement c'est un échec
bon c'est comme ça tous les rapports ne
disent pas forcément ça y ait des débats
on lit les rapports comme on veut et on
fait lit on fait dire aux rapports sont
en tout cas clairement le chemin de la
baisse en france tout est simple des
entreprises surtout les petites
il est clair que l'objectif des 35
heures n'a pas été atteint en termes de
création d'emplois point numéro 1 au
numéro 2 oui c'est vrai les gens ont
envie d'avoir des loisirs
je connais bien le problème j'ai été dix
ans dans les mêmes de loisirs jeux
loisirs
en développement donc voyez moi nous
étions très attachés au fait que nos
concitoyens puissent avoir le plus de
plaisir possible sauf que il faut des
moyens pour pouvoir avoir des loisirs
aujourd'hui vous avez beaucoup de jeunes
qui ont tout simplement envie de gagner
de l'argent
laissons-leur gagner leur vie visiteurs
lesquels il ya le travail en france les
entreprises ont les carnets de commandes
assez remplies pour que les jours d'un
juge mais envahir son nom de l'économie
est atone n'y a pas de croissance ce
métier tout à l'heure on disait
monsieur mâcon qui joue pas a eu des
propos très imprudent consistante
vouloir payer les heures supplémentaires
au même prix que les heures normales
c'est de la folie bien évidemment il
faut au contraire encourager nos
salariés à travailler plus dans de
bonnes conditions avec des augmentations
sensibles de la rémunération de ses
heures supplémentaires
cependant et encore faut-il qu'il y ait
un peu de liberté aux rimes il n'y en a
pas suffisamment par conséquent dans
notre métier en plus et notre métier
s'inscrit dans un domaine qu'elle
l'industrie du tourisme qui est en plein
développement dans notre pays non on le
voit bien les décisions excellente
ailleurs qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement pour la promotion du
tourisme va apporter beaucoup de
d'emplois supplémentaires sauf que
aujourd'hui nous sommes à 50 mille
emplois non pourvus dans notre secteur
d'activité
donc vous pensez bien que nous avons
tout intérêt à ce que les salariés se
sentent bien chez nous et qu'est ce qui
se passe pour qu'il se sente bien
un d'avoir des relations sociales de
bonne qualité 2 d'abord évidemment des
salaires des rémunérations motivantes
les accords d'entreprise c'est un autre
point qui va être abordé avec cette loi
du travail favier or tous loué son
rappel jeunesse qui est ce qu'un accord
d'entreprise
à quel moment on parle d'accord
d'entreprise on parle d'accord
d'entreprise contient un accord signé
entre la direction de l'entreprise et
des organisations syndicales
représentatives qui représente au moins
30% des salariés donc ça c'est la règle
actuelle d'accord l'accord est valable
et c'est la règle actuelle si la
majorité des syndicats ne s'y opposent
pas donc là c'est là aussi où il ya des
débats et des propositions qui sont
faites à l'heure actuelle pour passer à
une majorité d'engagement faire qu'un
accord est valable qu'en plus des
syndicats représentant plus de 50% des
salariés le signe ou alors la voie du
référendum par les salariés qui aussi a
été évoqué oui c'est mon cas la menace
du travail et la belle connerie
ces accords d'entreprise les rendre plus
flexible en tout cas plus possible dans
le monde de l'entreprise aujourd'hui en
france c'est quelque chose qui est
intéressant pour la pour la cgt c'est
une piste de réflexion on est pour qui
est quand même un cadre général qui
puisse protéger les salariés qui est
d'abord le code du travail qui sont
ensuite il accords de branche par grands
secteurs professionnels
après bien sûr on est aussi pour
négocier dans l'entreprise évidemment
parce qu on est d'accord aussi qu'il
faut s'adapter aux réalités de
l'activité mais pas en les pénalisant
forcément les salariés en étant des deux
côtés de bonne foi quand une entreprise
comme peugeot dans son usine en
certaines périodes de l'année
mais les salariés au chômage partiel et
à d'autres périodes leur demande leur
impose même de travailler le samedi
voilà est-ce qu'il ya de la bonne foi
s'il ya accord ça veut dire que il ya
encore des trucs
sauf que là ce n'était pas dans le cadre
d'un accord d'entreprise c'est dans le
cadre du droit commun et après il ya
aussi la question des très petites
entreprises qui qui préoccupe
effectivement la cgt parce que c'est un
nombre de salariés important est en
dessous de 11 salariés il n'y a même pas
de délégué du personnel
donc comment ces salariés là vont avoir
des représentants vont avoir des lieux
pour s'informer et discuter
c'est quelque chose que la cgt porte de
longue date et on commence à avancer un
tout petit peu avec la mise en place des
commissions paritaires régionales
non c'est pas encore suffisant mais
c'est un début pour avoir un dialogue
effectivement dans le territoire au
niveau des branches professionnelles
florence marque avait souri alors j'ai
trouvé ça extrêmement intéressant de
pouvoir permettre d'avoir un référendum
au sein de l'entreprise dès lors que
l'accord qui est signé et signé par des
syndicats minoritaires ces liens entre
30 et 49 % puisque la réforme dit
maintenant qu'il faut que les accords
soient signés par des partenaires
sociaux majoritaire celles qui ont eu
plus de 50 % aux élections au premier
tour il gouvernement à mon avis est
rendu compte que c'est mission
impossible d'avoir des accords signés
par les partenaires sociaux et qui est
d'emblée 50%
deux signatures de partenaires sociaux
et je pense que fait ressortir la voie
de référendum pour consolider un accord
minoritaire d'ailleurs signé par des
partenaires sociaux qui ont entre 30 et
40 9% de pouvoir couvrir cet accord par
un référendum par des salariés et bloqué
le droit d'opposition des syndicats
majoritaires me paraît enfin moi ça me
paraît très très bien je suis pas sûr
que ça convienne parfaitement aux
syndicats et surtout je trouve que c'est
assez en opposition avec un des
principes écrit par robert badinter dans
les soixante et un principe qui l'a
remis au gouvernement puisqu'il disait
dans un de ces principes que finalement
les représentants des salariés et
exclusivement ses représentants là
peuvent signer des accords donc il
rappelle quand même dans ses principes
que ce sont les partenaires sociaux qui
représente les salariés de manière
collective et là on est en train de dire
oups on est allé à 50% c'est peut-être
trop
donc pour pouvoir couvrir les accords de
30 % et + jusqu'à 50 il faudrait qu'on
passe par la voie de référendum et je
pense qu'ils tirent finalement l'exemple
de la fnac où ils ont eu et smart aussi
où ils ont lu ils ont signé des accords
minoritaire des référendum avec des gens
qui disent oui oui on est d'accord et un
droit d'opposition derrière d'un
syndicat majoritaire qui a bloqué
finalement l'accord tel que signé donc
je pense qu'ils sont en train d'essayer
de contourner un peu le problème de
cette manière là jean-luc madec par
exemple dans un restaurant comment
comment se passent les discussions avec
vos salariés
elle se passe très très bien cependant
vous avez raison madame bourreau dans
les petites entreprises
ray combien de salariés excusez moi
d'ailleurs à ce propos dix listes plus
mon épouse et moi c'est 12 donc dans les
petites entreprises c'est vrai la
représentation syndicale n'existe pas il
n'y a pas d'obligation d'avoir un
délégué du personnel en dessous de 11
salariés
je suis pour ma part totalement
favorable à ce que les salariés soient
mieux représentés quand on sait qu'ils
représentent les syndicats les grands
pour lesquelles j'ai le plus profond
respect qu on sait très bien que c'est
la fonction publique les grandes
entreprises et très peu des petites
entreprises 66 % des salariés sont issus
des petites boîtes moins de 20 salariés
bon à un moment donné il va bien falloir
que le législateur donc le politique
lance un signe réel
pour qu'il y ait une vraie
représentation des salariés mais c'est
la même chose pour les patrons tu dors
que moi je ne me sens pas conçus de
totalement représentée par le medef
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour florence
bien entendu et pour ce qu'elle fait
j'ai aussi le respect du fait que les
chambres de commerce soit
essentiellement aujourd'hui avec des
listes du medef ce qui fait que 16 %
seulement des entreprises en france ont
voté aux dernières élections pour
mission de commerce 7 à tomber par terre
c'est à dire que 84% des entreprises qui
n'avaient qu'une enveloppe avec un
timbre déjà mis à poster n'ai pas
répondu à la sollicitation des chambres
consulaires pour leur élection
c'est un des vrais problèmes en france
et je pense que nous serons toujours
inspirés avec nos amis de la cgt et les
autres syndicats d'ailleurs et aussi
avec nos amis du medef pour avoir une
meilleure représentation des salariés et
des entreprises dans ce pays c'est un de
nos fléau quand finalement si je
comprends bien tombés d'accord
malgré ce qu'on peut croire parfois sur
le nom sonia porot assure sur la
négociation collective et le référendum
si les syndicats majoritaires s'oppose à
un accord c'est qu'ils ont des raisons
puisque tous les syndicats la cgt y
compris quand un accord apporte des
avancées
ils sont signés ces accords dont il faut
se poser il faut il faut se poser des
questions
là l'enjeu aussi c'est comment on
discute avec les salariés quelle
question oppose dans un référendum
les échanges qu'on a eu ça montre que si
un salarié accepte de travailler en
heures supplémentaires ou acceptent de
travailler le dimanche par exemple c'est
essentiellement pour des raisons
financières
c'est pas voilà parce qu'il a juste
envie de travailler plus ou qu'il est
uniquement passionné par son métier
ça peut arriver mais enfin c'est pas la
majorité des cas crois qu'ils croyaient
être une notion qui rendent service et
un dessin x dans certains métiers oui
bien sûr il ya des métiers où la
continuité elle est nécessaire et dans
ce cas là bien sûr que le travail de
nuit le travail du dimanche
il faut qu'il existe ça il n'y a aucun
souci après c'est comment on regarde à
compenser les conséquences que ça a sur
la santé parce que c'est prouvé que le
travail de nuit que les horaires décalés
que le fait de ne pas avoir forcément 2
jours de repos consécutifs dans la
semaine ça d impact à moyen et à long
terme sur la santé
donc c'est comment on compense on
compense tout ça mais qu'est ce que vous
faites des deux millions et demi de
patrons qui eux sont dans ces conditions
là qui travaillent 70 heures par semaine
souvent d'ailleurs pour un grand nombre
d'entre eux à peine pour un smic vous ne
faites pas attention à leur santé à eux
ils ont pas le droit eux aussi d'avoir
un peu de considérer la lui refuse je
pense qu'il fait la confédération pour
toute la vie vous avez vous aussi une
expérience professionnelle au delà de
votre avocate
c'est notre gros noms je dirais pas la
grimace mais dans une autre vie j'ai été
aussi négociateurs côté patronal pendant
plusieurs années je signais des accords
négociés avec mes partenaires sociaux
une étude dans un groupe où il y en
avait beaucoup j'en avais 7
j'avais tout le panel de des syndicats
et concrètement il ya ceux qui
s'engagent il ya ceux qui s'opposent et
au milieu on s'est souvent retrouvé avec
un gros seins ce qu'on appelait le
ventre-mou salaires des gens qui
n'étaient ni pour ni contre
et à un moment qu est ce qu on fait
comme on n'avance pas ce même pour une
direction à voir appliquer un accord
kirk est signé par des syndicats qui
représentent que 30% des salariés
sincèrement c'est pas satisfaisant je
suis d'accord avec vous quand il ya une
opposition il ya quand même un acte
d'opposition entre 2 qu'est ce qu'on
fait
un accord à 30% pas de syndicats qui
s'opposent comment qu'est ce qu'on fait
sonia pour une réponse rageuse sonia
powered games pas les choquer pour le
medef et après le oui à gérer un petit
complément sur sur le référendum dans le
cadre de la réforme qui est prévu par
ministère du travail
le référendum est lancé par le syndicat
minoritaire il est pas lancé par la
direction
donc ça c'est important je dire ces
syndicats minoritaires qui a signé qui
va dire je lance le référendum est donc
c'est lui qui va peut être bloquée le
syndicat majoritaire donc c'est pas faut
pas penser que c'est le patron qui va
lancer le référendum pour couvrir
l'accord minoritaire c'est quand même un
point relativement inquiétante quand
même des entreprises dans les exemples
qu'on a dit james était c'était
entreprises et si on prend l'exemple de
smart
on a posé à l'ensemble des salariés donc
les cadres les ingénieurs les
techniciens les ouvriers les employés
la même question sur la durée on va dire
moyenne du temps de travail
sauf que encore une fois ces salariés
n'ont pas tous les mêmes conditions
c'est pas la même chose quand on fait
des 3,8 ou qu'on ai je leur dis qu'on
est cadre qu'on est dans un forfait jour
qui est tellement peu encadré
aujourd'hui j'ai quand même eu plusieurs
condamnations et onze accords de branche
qui ont été invalidés parce que
justement les durées maximum journalière
hebdomadaire etc ne sont pas du tout
encadré pas forcément un cadre qui fait
déjà plus de 40 heures c'est même
quarante six heures 60 pour les cadres
au forfait jour en moyenne et a
effectivement si on lui dit passer de 35
à 39 heures lui voit pas le problème
parce qu'il en fait déjà beaucoup plus
donc oui il faut il faut qu'on regarde
vraiment les choses telles qu'elles sont
je peux pas vous laisser dire que les
consoles du marché
we will rapide réponse des conventions
de forfait sont hyper encadrés par la
jurisprudence part à la cour européenne
de justice par les directives
européennes par les conventions
collectives qui ont été re va se passe
des organisations syndicales dont la cgt
avec son union générale jour ingénieurs
cadres et techniciens apporter des
affaires en justice
certes mais maintenant c'est quand même
relativement doux
obligé de vous couper dans vos
discussions qui étaient très
intéressantes merci à vous quatre
d'avoir participé à cette émission
d'avoir participé à ce débat d'avoir
apporté vos réflexions vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur tv fil 78
points comme bonne soirée à tous